κάτι που μου έλειπε από τις συλλογή μου στεευθώ και ολιμπιονίκης και οι πόλιπιαγόνες κιο
χαμηλοπιπέδου κοινοπολδιακούςσμεςσο γιακούς και διαφορια λέαγώνες τώρα τι κάνει ο κύρια πως μεδιχωείτεσ στην όμως
πονδία είσε κάπου όχι δεν είμαι στην ομοσποντία δεν είμαικάπου εμαι στην ουσίαν οι με
συνεργάτης μετων κι να σήκοσλλογο πράξανδρος πρωπονητής αλμάτωνκαι κύρίος το άλμα εσύψως όμως παράλλαγι μνάζω
και άλλους αθλητές από άλλος συλλόγους καιέχω δημιουργήσει τη δική μου ακατημία στίβου την άλμα
θα δηδούμε στις συνέχεια για να αναλύσουμε και την το άλμα κυριαγώ να σερωήσω όταν
ξεκινούσες μικρός φαντάστηκες οί θα έχεισ αυτή την πορεία τέσσερεις ολι πιο άδες με ξερετικές
εφανις κάποιους απααυτές διακρίσεις εσε διάφορες διοργανώσεις όταν ήσουν μικρός και έκανε στα πρώτα βήματα
τα πρώτα το πρώτο αγώνα σκέφτηκε ε θα υτανείσε αυτό το επίπεδο σίγουρα όχι δεν
δεν μπορείς να φανταστής ότιηλικία δέκαέντεκα χρονών όταν πρωτογνωρίστηκαμε το άλμα εσύψως και ξεκίνησαν αλαμβάνο
μέρος ε επαρχιακούς αγόνες παρένθεση οιμουντρίτος τέταρτος της επαρχιακούς αγώνες δενήμουν ποτέ πρωτος και όπως
ποτέ δεν είμουν και πρός τους παγκύπριους σε μαθετικόν πρωτάθλημα όμως πάντα κάτι μέσα μου
έγε ότι πρέπει να προσπαθήσεις πίστευα στις δυνατότητες που είχα τότε ότι αντελαμβανόμονα εκείνι την
εποχή σίγουρα όταν περνούσαν τα χρόνια και μεγάλοννα ωρεί μαζα προσπαθούσαν βρω τρόπο το πως
να σκαρφαλόσο στο πιο ψηλλοσκαλο πάτι τουλξον εγχώρια στην κύπρο περνόντας ο καιρόσίγουρα άλλαζαν και
ιστόχι επιστελειςσπεσισότιος των εαυτό σου και κείταιος πάντων που κατάλαβα ότι μπορώ να κάμωκάτι ήταν